what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some news about Shang
Chi 2 and if you happen to not be aware
yes shangshi 2 is confirmed and has been
confirmed for some time now it's
confirmed by Kevin feige the president
of Marvel Studios and director Destin
Daniel who directed Shang Chi and
the legend of the ten Rings is also
going to be directing Avengers the Kang
Dynasty this is confirmed and also Shang
Chi too which is also confirmed well
today we have an update from Chung Chi
himself simu Liu we'll talk about what
he has said and everything we know about
Xiang Chi 2 so far as well as talk about
a little rumor going around of King the
conqueror's connection to the ten rings
and I'll issue a spoiler warning right
before we talk about that in case you
happen to not want to hear it so don't
worry about that and if you want to stay
up to date on chongqi 2 and the MCU be
sure to subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and also if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win and
Xbox series X a PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items we pick a winner
at the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item so somebody asked
simu Liu on social media what's the
status on chunk Chi 2 which simulyu
responded himself stating was told it
would follow Avengers but that keeps
pushing back due to circumstances Beyond
My Control hope to have more concrete
news to share soon so Xiang Chi 2 keeps
getting delayed which isn't that big of
a surprise a lot of Marvel studios's
projects have been delayed of recent but
here's the thing there are many
different ways to interpret what Seema
Leo is stating here one is that the
movie is being delayed directly by
itself not linked to any other projects
being delayed but Chung Chi 2
specifically has been delayed for
whatever reasons however I don't think
that this is the case I believe that
Xiang Chi 2 has to follow directly the
events that take place in Avengers the
King Dynasty and there are a few reasons
around this now semen Liu basically
confirmed with this message that it's
supposed to follow the next Avengers
film The Kang Dynasty we thought maybe
it could come out before the King
Dynasty because we know that there is a
connection with Shang Chi and Kang
specifically because of the 10 Rings
their Kang technology in fact we
basically saw ring technology again and
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania in
King's Quantum city so we knew there was
a connection there but we simply didn't
know if Xiang Chi 2 was coming out
before or after Kang Dynasty this
confirms it is supposed to come out
after now the delay is most likely due
to the delay of the Kang Dynasty itself
that movie has been pushed back a year
and consequentially Avenger Secret Wars
was also pushed back a year so shanxi is
coming out between the two of them now
like I mentioned before both movies are
going to be directed by Destin Daniel
critten the director of the first Shang
Chi movie and since he is directing both
the King Dynasty and shangchi 2. that
means he is most likely dealing with the
story of xiangchi too being a
consequence of whatever is happening in
the Kang Dynasty so the events of the
King Dynasty do have to take place first
for shangshi 2 to happen in which Dustin
Daniel will direct that story now
also something else to consider is that
the rumored title for shangchi 2 right
now is wreckage of time and this rumored
title does make a lot of sense because
we know that after the King Dynasty The
Avengers are most likely going to lose
to Kang or at least lose to some
variance of Kang and this is where the
Multiverse kind of starts to collapse
and in turn time itself will kind of
start to collapse where time could be
wrecked therefore we get the title
wreckage of time so what might end up
happening in shangshi 2 is that they are
dealing with the aftermath of what
happens in the King Dynasty which could
be the start of incursions universes
colliding with each other throughout the
Multiverse causing the Multiverse itself
to become unstable and when the
Multiverse becomes unstable a lot of
crazy stuff happens we've already kind
of seen it in Spider-Man no way home you
start to get character from other
universes going into universes that
they're not supposed to be in therefore
further causing the Multiverse itself to
be even more fragile basically after the
King Dynasty it's all gonna kind of
start to hit the fan and Secret Wars is
going to be where the Multiverse is
pretty much destroyed and collapsing and
then it's going to be up to our team of
Heroes consisting of multiple different
teams at this point throughout multiple
different universes to come together and
fix the destruction that has happened to
the universe in the comics it's Reid
Richards who has a very big role in this
part in restoring the Multiverse to what
it used to be and luckily for us Reed
Richards is about to enter the MCU
before the events of the King Dynasty so
no doubt after Avengers the King Dynasty
happens read Richards and the Fantastic
Four will have a major role to play both
between Avengers King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars but also during
Avengers Secret Wars so it seems like
shangchi is going to have some role to
play with time after Avengers the King
Dynasty takes place now here's where
we're going going to dive into possible
spoilers for the Marvels it's not a
crazy huge spoiler and if you've been
following the channel it pretty much
confirms what we already know this is
just a rumor at this point in time we do
not know if it's confirmed but some
insiders are backing this up and that is
that one of the post-credit scenes for
the Marvels is going to be Kang looking
at Xiang Chi's 10 Rings also looking at
Miss Marvel's Bengal both of which are
supposed to be based off of what we know
already Kang technology and we do know
that Ronan the accuser's daughter is
going to be the main villain of the
Marvels and we've seen in the trailer
that she actually has another Bengal now
we learned in Miss Marvel that there are
supposed to be two Bengals and now we
have seen both Bengals and now the
energy from the Bengals is being used
which might be linked to Kang the same
thing goes for the 10 rings when the 10
rings are used perhaps Kang can feel it
or since it because we never did find
out in the first Shang Chi film them
where exactly when Wu got the Rings from
in fact they made it a point to be
pretty ambiguous about it saying that
nobody truly does know how he got them
some say this story some say this story
some say another story it seems like
that was pretty intentional and the
reason for that could be because they
are going to further explain in shangchi
that it's connected to Kane the
Conqueror the overall big bad of the
Multiverse Saga and since Kang the
Conqueror is the master of time I would
not be surprised if the 10 rings do have
the ability to possibly Multiverse
travel or time travel after all they are
a product of Kang the master of time and
I do hope they answer the question in
shangchi 2 of where they got the Rings
from because I would love to know if
Kang actually gave them to win Wu
himself and when will was kind of
working with Kang a little bit did
win-woo know about King or did Kang
simply leave them somewhere for win-woo
to find because Kang saw the future of
what winwoo would do with the Rings and
Kang wanted that to happen a lot of
unanswered questions that I would love
to find out but the Rings mostly likely
do have some time properties connected
to them in some way shape or form so the
next film is the wreckage of time and is
about time traveling or Multiverse
traveling in the Multiverse Saga that
would make sense and it would make sense
that shangshi has to use the Rings to
try and fix things now I don't think
he's going to be successful because
that's how we get secret Wars but that
is going to be pretty much the main
theme after Avengers the King Dynasty
The Avengers and the other Heroes trying
to figure out how to stop incursions
from happening and how to stop the
destruction of the Multiverse slash King
from taking over the entire Multiverse
itself so Xiang Chi 2 is probably coming
out after Avengers the King Dynasty and
the reason that it is getting pushed
back is probably because it has to come
after that film because it is directly
linked to the events that are going to
take place in that film so I don't think
we have much to fear about here I think
the only reason it got pushed back was
because the King Dynasty got pushed back
sadly a lot of things did get pushed
back but we do have some exciting films
coming up like the Marvels and Deadpool
three but let us know your best thoughts
and theories about Xiang Chi 2 in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to enter in
our giveaway and stay up to date on the
MCU and if you want to further support
the channel you can check us out on
patreon you can check out our website
and our Discord server as well and of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf